Mark: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Factorio with Bob. Hi, Bob!
Bob: What's up, Bob?
Or, you know, whatever.
Mark: Yeah, funny joke. We've been doing that for so many times now.
Bob: Nailed it.
Mark: Nailed it. Every opening that we've done is a winner.
Mark: So-
Bob: It's funny every time, don't worry.
Mark: Pretty much. So, as everyone sees, this is completely different from what we've had before.
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: Uhm, nothing blew up. We just had to go over to Bob hosting, which means that this is his game,
Mark: ...that he saved and, uhm, I just g-, I'm gonna make some casual-
Bob: Do tell!
Mark: Yeah, I'm gonna make some casual observations on the quality of this. Uhm...
Bob: Okay.
Mark: When Bob does something, he always overdoes it. So, as you-
Bob: Oh, yeah!
Mark: -can see with the boiler situation, he's got literally- You've got
eleven different boilers for what amounts to
a tiny base.
Which is good! Because this means we have room to grow.
But also, the wall placement was a little bit questionable, because there's literally
no way to get out on the bottom side?
Mark: You're kinda like, boxed in.
Bob: Well, like, you know, we can,
we can deconstruct the wall and then...
Bob: There's a hole.
Mark: I guess.
Bob: Right there on the wall.
And then y- Just take it and put it back.
Mark: Yeah, I guess, you know. I, I can't really criticize all that much.
Bob: It's like, it's like a gate.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: It's like a gate.
Mark: Except we don't have a gate yet.
Mark: So, when we last left off-
Bob: [Snickers]
Mark: -we were first touching on assembly loops
and this is Bob's attempt to do an assembly loop, and you can see it's-
Bob: Hey, it works! -ish...
Mark: [Laughs] It- How does it work?
Mark: It was literally a j-
Bob: Oh, what-
Mark: It was jam packed so much, nothing was moving.
Bob: When you clear it out and then reset it,
Bob: and it has iron in it, which it did not previously,
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: that's a problem.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: It- It did, it works when it's fully stocked. It just ran out of iron,
'cus I don't know how to stock things.
Mark: Sure, okay, that's what it is.
Bob: No, that's the truth!
Mark: Okay. So, generally, though, this is going pretty well, because in the north sector
we have dedicated iron production.
And just below it we have dedicated steel production,
and that was totally intentional and went that way because we planned it.
Bob: Yeah!
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: It's been like that on purpose since the beginning.
Mark: Uh-huh! Exactly. And I-
Bob: Probably.
Mark: Eh, maybe.
We'll, we'll, we'll see in a little bit.
But now we're gonna try to make another assembly loop that's gonna work a little bit better
than the last one. And it's gonna be able to make everything that we need much faster.
Mark: Hopefully, again. Hopefully.
Bob: Maybe.
Mark: Maybe.
Mark: We are not a hundred percent sure.
Bob: Maybe not.
Mark: Yeah.
We're not a hundred percent sure about anything that's going on this one.
But, we're gonna try.
We're gonna try real hard and I need to wait until I got more iron,
because someone just took all the iron out of the chest.
Bob: Yeah, I, I had to restock the assembly loops that are working so well. Okay?
Mark: [Laughs]
Bob: So...
Mark: You're amazingly-
Bob: Look, I just got science out of all the assembly loops!
Mark: Wow!
Bob: I will put into our science machines.
Bob: They're doing science!
Mark: My god, even though we didn't select our research.
Mark: Holy crap!
Bob: Oh yeah! I was wondering why they weren't doing stuff.
Mark: Yeah. Remember the research-
Bob: You've gotta select the research!
Mark: Yeah. You planned to do another research besides the one before.
Bob: So, should I do the efficiency? Lab efficiency? Or should we move on to important stuff?
Mark: It- I w- I would go to important stuff because it, it's probably important, what we need.
Bob: Alright.
Mark: Cause if we're gonna start doing the oil, like, we can research plastics right now. We could do that.
Bob: Yeah, so we need plastics, right?
Mark: Yeah, we could do plastics. And that's important for the other upgrades of the electronic system,
like, if you go to your intermediate products, the advanced circuit and the processing units, they need
plastic bars, which we do not have and we can only get through the use of oil refineries.
Mark: Makes sense?
Bob: Neat. Mark: Neat!
Mark: So much fun!
Bob: So I should- "refer"- "refearch" oil, [garbled speak]
Mark: [Laughs] Bob, are you having a stroke? Oh, God!
[Both laugh]
Bob: Alright, so I've got, uh...
Got some oil processing. So I've got basic oil processing.
Bob: So we really do need plastics as the next step.
Mark: Yes, we do.
Bob: Okay, plastics next.
Mark: Yeah, that- that's literally the only thing keeping this back.
But to do that, before that, I have perfected in my mind -- admittedly, it's only in my mind --
the new generation of material processing loops that's gonna hearken us in to a new day, a new dawn
Bob: The new era!
Mark: A new era of advanced materials processing, the likes of which have never been seen on this earth.
Bob: Oh, yeah!
Mark: Have I sensationalized it enough for you?
Bob: I'm ready!
Mark: Okay, good.
Mark: Do you kno- uhh, do you-
Bob: Do you, do you still need resources?
Bob:I'll go gather resources for you.
Mark: Mark: I, I need, uhm,
I, I'm good on resources. Do you have a bunch of conveyor belts?
Because this is going to be a giant bitch.
Bob: Uh, I've got fifty conveyor belts.
Mark: That would be very helpful, please. I need them. I've got none.
Bob: Let me run back towards you.
Mark: Can you just throw them to me or do you have to put them in a chest?
Bob: How do I- Yeah, how do I...?
Mark: I don't- [Laughs]
Bob: How do I, uh...
Bob: You know what?
Mark: It's like the episode of South Park,
Mark: ...where in the World of Warcraft episode.
Mark: "How do I-"
Bob: Yeah! [Laughs]
Mark: "How do I give it to you?"
Mark: "How do I" "How do I do it?"
Bob: Just, just, there.
Mark: Thank you. Alright. You can take your chest back-
Bob: You're welcome.
Mark: ...because it's in the way of all the shit I'm about to build.
Bob: Oh, okay. Awesome.
Mark: Yeah, okay. So watch and be amazed. Are you ready?
Bob: Oh, I'm amazed already, man.
Mark: Thanks. That's what I usually get when people are in my presence.
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: Okay. Here we go.
Bob: I am interested to see how the explanation that you furnished for me actually translates.
Mark: [Laughs]
Bob: I think I understand, but-
Mark: Yeah...
Bob: ...that does not mean very much.
Mark: Yeah. What was the explanation that I said it was like, "Okay, so you've got an inner loop-"
Bob: introduce long grabbers because you use the inner loop for resources, but the outer loop is for science only
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: or some kind of thing like that.
Mark: Yeah. Okay. So, just, just,
Bob: Some kind of shenanigans.
Mark: just you wait, because this is going to be
Mark: banan-
Bob: This already looks wrong.
Mark: Th- No, come on! Have a little more faith than that!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: It's obviously exactly the same as everything else I've built. Except, you know, it's just going
to use long hand- No, this is wrong, you were right, it's wrong.
Mark: [Laughs]
Bob: Yeah, I was gonna say, I- I- did- didn't you- isn't there a,
Mark: Shoosh!
Bob: a space in this thing for a part of this?
Mark: Shoosh! Shoosh!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: You don't need to worry about a thing. It's okay!
Bob: Alright. There you go. That looks more right!
Mark: Yeah, this is more right. Okay. So, now...
Bob: It's righterrific!
Mark: Yeah. So, why don't you, why don't you just be useful and go, go do something else while I figure this out?
Bob: No, I wanna watch the majesty. I don't wanna observe.
Mark: Are you sure? I mean, maybe something
Bob: Oh-
Mark: ...needs fuel somewhere?
Bob: Nah, I just refueled everything. We're good on fuel, though, don't worry about it.
Mark: [Laughs] Literally, literally everything was just refueled.
Bob: Yeah, every- Everything is fueled up, baby.
Mark: Thank you. Okay. Uhm, let's see, I need to go get more iron.
Bob: Do you need me to make some grabby-grabbers for you?
Mark: Yes, please make grabby-grabbers. You know where to put the grabby-grabbers.
Bob: You want f- eight long ones and eight, and eight short, and eight-
Mark: No no no no no, no no no no.
Bob: No?
Mark: No no no no.
Mark: Not yet.
Bob: How many long ones you want?
Mark: What I want, what I want,
Bob: Okay.
Mark: ...what I really, really want is...
Bob: You wanna-
Mark: to have a goddamn clue of what the hell I'm doing,
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: because, frankly, this, this already-
Bob: Already asking you what you need is very helpful.
Mark: [Laughs] Yeah. So what, what, what was in my mind is already looking different than what I've put down.
Bob: No, no, stick, stick to your guns, man! I think I'm, I think I'm right with you.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: I think you want another loop running around right outside, right?
Mark: Yeah, yeah, exactly. There's, there's gonna be like a-
Bob: And then, and then you'd like a long grabby-grabbers?
Bob: To, to put stuff on the outside loop?
Mark: Mm-hmm. Yeah. And on the short side of the loops --basically there's gonna be like a
short side and a long side-- there's gonna be a, a long grabbies that reach over it?
Mark: And put it-
Bob: And pull stuff off of the middle loop?
Mark: Yeah. And then... [Grunts] It's so hard!
Bob: No, I'm with you! I'm with you, I'm with you, I'm with you.
Mark: So, it's like, it's like gaped, see? It's like that far away, is the second loop. Except on the
short side, like it goes like this. You see what I'm talking about here? So that there's room for, uh...
One, two, uh... On the outside, and then in middle is the long grabbies going back and forth, and then the supply
chest for the inner side going back and forth inside. You see what I mean?
Mark: Does that make any sense?
Bob: I... Heard what you said.
Mark: [Laughs]
Bob: Just keep going, just keep going. I'll help- I'll pitch in once I understand more.
Mark: Okay [Still laughing]
Bob: Do you need more, do you need more road?
Mark: Uhm...
Bob: I can make more road.
Mark: Yeah, we need more road. Put more bricks down. [Laughing]
Bob: Okay.
Mark: It's the only thing-
Bob: No, not road! No, t- it's transporter belt. I'm...
Mark: Yeah, transporter belt.
Bob: Fuck... stupid pants.
Mark: Yeah, stupid pants.
Bob: Stupid pants.
Mark: Alright, so.
Bob: Oh, this is getting "fance".
Mark: Okay. But do you see-
Bob: I meant to say fancy now.
Mark: Do you see... Yeah, "fance" is the new-
Bob: I, I th- think I see it.
Bob: No garantee.
Mark: You think you see.
[Making fun of Bob's lisp] "I 'sink' I see, I 'sink' I see".
Mark: Okay.
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: Just...
Mark: Hang on here, because this is a- this is gonna be a wild ride.
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: Woah.
Mark: Okay. So.
Bob: This is gonna be amazing!
Mark: It's gonna be...
Bob: So amazing!
Mark: [Sighs] Okay. So, I think, I think what I have to do here
is make... That's not gonna work.
No, it wi- it will work. Okay.
I have to make indentations on the loop, such that there's room here to reach over directly
into these, and then these put the, out of these, so... [Groans] Okay.
Bob: No, I know. I see where you're going, I see where you're going with that.
Mark: Do you? It doesn't, like-
Bob: I do.
Mark: When you, when you say it like that it sounds
Mark: ...really condescending.
Bob: No, I, I actually do. I'm being a dick about it, but I do understand. I do understand the point of that.
Mark: It's just, my instincts when, when talking to you are like: "Is he, is he, is he being a dick to me?"
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: "Is he making fun? My emotions can't handle it."
Alright. Okay. Ah, shit, I forgot. These need to be farther out. Oh no, wait, I can, I can long-handle these.
These can be long handles.
Bob: Just get my long grabby-grabby.
Mark: Oh no, no. They need to be on the belt. No, yeah, I gotta, I gotta do one more out.
But, as people can see, this looks really cool.
Mark: And when things look cool,
Bob: It does!
Mark: ...they will always work. Because, life-
Bob: Things look cool, that is clearly the best way to do them.
Mark: Yeah. If I was really fancy, I would of had these belts going the opposite direction, that would have been...
Mark: Would have been super cool.
Bob: Yeah, I was thinking about that and I, I didn't say anything out loud, I didn't wanna get in your way, but
Mark: [Laughs] Thanks.
Bob: It would look really cool, if they were going in opposite directions.
Mark: Thanks, Bob. Thanks. Thanks.
Bob: But it looks cool your way too, you know, your ways get-
Mark: [Laughs] I just-
Bob: Am I helping?
Mark: No...
Bob: Is my, is my commentary helpful to you? [Laughs]
Mark: My ego is just going lower and lower every time we do this.
Mark: Did you make grabby-grabbies?
Bob: [Silence]
Bob: No, I did not.
Mark: Goddammit, Bob!
Bob: You didn't tell me how many- I don't know how many you need or what kind! I don't, I, it's, [grunts]
Mark: Okay. Alright. I'll make grabby-grabbies because-
Bob: Here, I'll make ten yellows.
Mark: Okay, that'll help. I'm gonna go get-
Bob: Then I'll make four long ones...
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Just to start.
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: And then, and, and... I'll put a chest down so that I can hand them to you,
Mark: Nice.
Bob: ...so that I don't have to try and comprehend where you want me to place them.
Mark: I love it already. It's, it's going really well.
Bob: Uhm...
Mark: Okay.
Mark: So... Alright. I got-
Bob: I made seven yellow ones. That's close. Almost.
Mark: Ah, fudge!
Bob: I, I swear to God, this game doesn't register my clicks sometimes,
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: I don't understand. I try!
Mark: You try really hard.
Bob: Trying count very carefully.
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: Alright. There's ten, ten yellows and four reds in that chest right there.
Mark: Thank you. I'm just gonna make a s-
Bob: Probably need more reds then, I'm gonna make-
Mark: No no no no, it's cool. I'm gonna make a small adjustment, and then we're gonna be golden.
Because I, I made one, two, short.
Bob: Oh, I also made you some more road.
Mark: [With a lisp] Thank you!
Bob: Or, conveyor belt. Whatever.
Mark: Thank you, Bob.
Bob: You cut out just perfectly, so it sounded like you said "Fuck you!"
Mark: [Laughs]
Bob: Fine, I will just take 'em all back, and you can do whatever you want!
Mark: Fuck you and fuck your conveyor belts!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: Fuck everything you tried to do to help me,
and fuck you!
Alright.
Mark: Okay.
Bob: I can, I can give you some of my patented, well planned out electrical grid up in here.
Mark: That is
Bob: That be, would that be useful?
Mark: ...really, really helpful. Really helpful, Bob.
Bob: Yeah?
Mark: That would be incredibly helpful. Please do.
Mark: Oh yeah, I forgot you made them. I was just making grabbers. Why was I doing that?
Bob: Yeah, they're sitting right there.
Mark: I'm such a dickhole.
Bob: All that stuff I said out loud, it wasn't a lie.
Mark: It wasn't- okay. I just, I'm so used to lies,
Mark: just nonstop lies.
Bob: I know it sounds like a lie.
Mark: Okay. So these long handles, they're going to grab in... okay.
Bob: Oh, man, we're actually out of coal.
Mark: What? No! That's impossible!
Bob: Well, I just put it all inside of stuff, but we're, we're like, low on coal, currently.
Mark: Well, that's- Okay, alright, then. That's weird.
Mark: Alright, then. So-
Bob: Come on, coal production.
Mark: Alright. So, the main limiting factors of these assembly machines is, the gears and the "sproyengs".
Mark: Or, the, the gears, yeah, and the copper c-
Bob: The sproyengs is out of their coal.
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: Shh, shh, shh.
Mark: They're not-
Bob: I mean- right, right, right. Sproyengs.
Bob: No, I got you.
Mark: Cus, they're not springs, but they're coiled copper, you know what I mean?
Mark: Like, it makes sense.
Bob: That's the sound they make when you look at them.
Mark: If you, if you think about it, really, if you weigh your options...
Bob: [Laughs] If you weigh your options?
Mark: It's like a sproyeng! Alright, sh-
Bob: I know, I, yeah, yeah.
Mark: Thanks, thanks, Bob.
Bob: Now that you said it like that?
Mark: Thanks, man.
Bob: Perfect sense.
Mark: Thanks man.
Mark: Okay, I'm actually gonna replace these-
Bob: So, it looks like our pollution is about to reach the bottom right, uhm, red dot of goof on map.
Mark: Oh, shit. Yeah, we should tell people. If, if, uh... Everyone look into the map. The kinda red hazy outline? That's the pollution level. And when those
Mark: touch the red dots --those are aliens--, they get pissed the fuck off, and then they wanna-
Bob: They come and murder us!
Mark: Yeah, they wanna come murder us real badly. So, we gotta get out of here before that happens.
Mark: Because otherwise we'd be dead.
Bob: I guess I am gonna make that a bunch of defenses.
Bob: I'm gonna, I'm gonna start producing turrets and try to space them out so that we can get some, some defensive coverage
Mark: Yes, please!
Bob: ...for when that apocalypse comes and whatever.
Mark: God, it's gonna be bad.
Mark: Okay. S-
Bob: Oh, why do I have two more long grabby-grabbies?
Mark: I do not know.
Bob: Do you need more long grabby-grabbies?
Mark: No. But you said you were going to use your patented power system to help me out, I, I, I distinctly remember that being-
Bob: Oh, I got it. Don't you, don't you worry. Are you ready for power?
Mark: I'm ready for power!
Bob: Are you ready for POWER?
Mark: [Shouting] I'm ready for power!
Bob: Alright, it's coming, baby.
Mark: Okay. Oh, Jesus. Oh, J- Oh, Geez. Oh, you're just- [Snickers] You're not even trying!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: Why? Good job, Bob. You did great. You nailed it.
Bob: Nailed it!
Mark: Yeah, you nailed it.
Bob: [Shouting] Everything has power no-
[Normal tone] oh, no it doesn't.
[Both laugh]
Mark: Yeah, they don't reach that far, Bob, it's, it's not that-
Bob: Everything has power now! No, it doesn't.
Mark: Uh-huh. Okay. Yeah, sure. Okay.
Bob: Hang on. I'm working on it.
Mark: Okay. What the f-
Mark: Bob! I need to put grabbies around there! Like, it's not that ready for power, it's only minorly ready for power!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: Please, Bob!
Bob: Well it- it's, it's fully powered now!
Mark: No!
Bob: Look, look, I've got presents for you.
Mark: No! No! They're all gonna laugh at you!
Bob: This is helpful?
Mark: At least we can see. At least we can see.
Bob: I just can't, I can't get over how symmetrical and well thought out all of your shit is, and then mine's just like, "WOO, WOOW!"
[Both laugh]
Mark: Well, uhm... I, I, you know, I can't fault you for trying. You, you did, you did good. You did real good.
Bob: Me trying? I did what I said I was gonna do.
Mark: Well, you know what? You're not a liar.
Mark: Definitely not-
Bob: I did exactly what I said I was gonna do, so...
Mark: Oh, God...
Bob: Nailed it.
Mark: Thank you, Bob. You are...
You are the light in my world.
Okay. So, as you can see, I forgot that the inner thing does not need, uh, it doesn't need...
Mark: Oh, fuck, what does it not need? [Grunts] Fuck-
Bob: Lots of stu- lots of stuff?
Mark: Oh, yeah, those need plates, that's right.
These need metal plates. Okay, so. Alright, so, this is gonna be, really cool, once you see
it go- oh, okay. So, before this episode ends, this is gonna go, and that's gonna be the sweetest thing you've ever seen in your goddamn life.
Mark: Okay. Just a little more... [Panting]
Bob: You can do it, Mark.
Mark: still some more.
Shit.
Okay.
Mark: Fuck, you put the power pole in the wrong place! Goddammit,
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: ...your fucking power poles! They're so-
Bob: Hey, you didn't give me pa-, you didn't give me "pacific"
Mark: [Laughs]
Bob: instructions, okay? I need "pacifics".
Mark: I need very
Bob: Or something.
Mark: ..."pacifics". We're gonna be quiet.
I'm thinking about
[Lispy] "pacifics"
Mark: Okay. And- oop! And...
Bob: Hey! Ohh, stuff's going on!
Mark: And... Okay, and my, my character's
Mark: still very crazy. I will, probably have to relog after this but, bam! See?
Bob: Oh, plastics' finished!
Mark: AND this is working! See? Do you see?
Bob: What's- I...
Mark: Okay. The only thing I don't have is a grabbing something and going to the outer loop yet. But that's gonna be fixed
Bob: Yeah.
Mark: ...very soon.
Bob: 'Cause the inner loop is working, there's something bringing the-
Mark: Shoosh! It's gonna happen!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: You don't have any faith!
Bob: Wait, wa-, wa-,wait, here. I got it, Mark.
Mark: Yeah?
Bob: Don't worry about it.
Mark: Uhh...
Bob: Don't you worry about a thing.
Mark: Well, we'll have to get to this in the next episode, because we're all out of time for this, so...
Thank you everybody so much for watching, but you guys see what I'm lo- I'm doing, right? Everyone at home? I'm not crazy!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: I hate that! How many times do I have to say I'm not crazy?
[Outro music starts faintly playing]
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: But yeah, thank you guys. I will see you-
Bob: I mean-
Mark: Bob, I'm trying to do the outro!
[Both laugh]
Mark: I'm not crazy! Thank you again, and as always, we'll see you in the next video.
Video...Bye-bye!
[Outro music playing]
...Who said I should drawn Arin and Danny as babies, fighthing each other.
Hello, Mr. Clown Man! You look happy to- O-kay! Am I underwater now?